président de la commission mixte
paritaire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
le rapporteur madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales chers
collègues la commission mixte paritaire
réunit hier pour examiner les
dispositions restants en discussion de
ce projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale 2023
a réussi à établir un texte commun
lors de ces travaux René Paul Savary et
moi-même avons veillé à rester fidèle à
l'esprit de la majorité sénatoriale
cette réforme dont nous savons demandera
des efforts aux Français doit atteindre
pleinement son but ramener notre système
de retraite à l'équilibre à l'horizon de
2030 afin de garantir sa soutenabilité
financière au bénéfice des générations
futures
c'est en ayant cet objectif en tête que
tout en s'inscrivant tout en inscrivant
ces marqueurs dans le texte le Sénat
aveillé en première lecture à rester
dans une épure financière proche de
l'équilibre
René Paul Savary vous détaillera
certains choix de la CMP qui se
traduiront par des coûts supplémentaires
pour le système de retraite par rapport
à la version du texte adopté par le
Sénat
néanmoins messieurs les ministres
j'espère que vous serez en mesure de
nous confirmer que le texte issu de la
commission mixte paritaire permet le
retour à l'équilibre des comptes en 2030
moyennant peut-être un nouvel ajustement
des taux de cotisation patronales
vieillesse et ATMP
en toute état de cause mes chers
collègues vous retrouverez dans le texte
qui vous est présenté les principales
mesures que nous avons examinées
et adopter tout au long de la semaine
dernière et même pour certaines depuis
plusieurs années dans le cadre des PLFSS
je pense naturellement au décalage
progressif de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
ainsi qu'à l'accélération de la réforme
Touraine sur lesquelles reposent
l'équilibre financier de ce PLFR SS je
pense aussi à la mise en extension
extinction des principaux régimes
spéciaux avec la clause dite du
grand-père au terme de laquelle les
personnes embauchées à compter du 1er
septembre 2023 dans les entreprises et
institutions concernées seront affiliés
au régime général pour le risque
vieillesse
je pense également à l'abandon du projet
de transfert aux URSSAF de l'activité de
recouvrement de l'agircarco et de la
Caisse des dépôts et consignations qui a
été confirmé par la CMP
enfin je vous précise que la CMP a
confirmé l'introduction dans l'annexe A
du principe de compensation intégrale
par l'état des 2023 des surcos engendrés
par la hausse de cotisations patronale
cnrcl pour les employeurs publics
concernés
du fait du maintien de ses nombreux
marqueurs du Sénat et avec les autres
dispositions qui vont vous être
présentées par René Paul Savary je vous
appelle mes chers collègues à approuvé
les conclusions de la commission mix
paritaire et je vous remercie de votre
attention merci madame le rapporteur
général
de donner la parole à notre collègue
René